bay south pole ici les à moins que
qu'est ce que les de quoi les est il
fait qu'est-ce qui composent les et
est-ce vraiment raisonnable de penser
que les mais aussi david thibeault et
vous autres n'est-ce que débite pour
comprendre de quoi est fait le monde
qu'on habite la philosophie à développer
la physique la physique a développé le
concept de mesures tout ce qu on mesure
tout ce qu'on prédit tout ce qu'on écrit
de notre monde est quantifié par la
physique sur différentes échelles comme
le mettre le pied
le yard le maïs ému nautique l'année
lumière le chaînon la perche le par
siècle furent longs lalieux l'unité
astronomique le pousse pousse mais ton
poste dans cette liste d'unité pour
insister sur le fait que les unités
c'est important une unité astronomique
c'est une unité astronomique et ce n'est
pas la même chose que un parent sec
on ne peut pas additionner des pommes et
des bananes disait peut-être votre prof
de maths
il nous faut pas non plus comparer des
unités astronomiques et départ sec comme
le disait peut-être votre prof de
physique pour comparer une unité
astronomique et un parent sec
les scientifiques convertissent l'un en
l'autre c'est exactement comme un taux
de change
le 9 janvier 2020 un franc suisse valait
1 dollar néo zélandais et 55 centimes un
franc suisse vaut donc plus que 1 dollar
néo zélandais ou devrais-je plutôt dire
un franc suisse vaut plus qu'un dollar
néo zélandais
le même problème se pose également pour
les fractions en mathématiques il ne
faut jamais additionner les cars et les
5e et il ne faut pas comparer 13 car
avec 16 5e ou plutôt pour comparer 13
car et c'est 5e il faut d'abord
convertir sait caresser 5e en une unité
commune et pour cela comme pour les
monnaies on peut s'appuyer sur les taux
de conversion entre les quarts les
cinquièmes alors il se trouve que un
quart est égal à 1 25 5e donc presque
arts sont égaux à 13 x 1,25 5e qui font
16 points 5/5 et donc 13/4 sont
légèrement plus que 16 5e la conversion
vers les mêmes unités permettent aussi
l'addition de différentes unités
combien font presque art + 16 5e 29
quelque chose non non car on ne peut pas
additionner des cars et des cinquièmes
tout comme on ne peut pas additionner
des francs suisses et des dollars néo
zélandais ou des pommes et des bananes
en revanche on sait désormais que 13 car
sont aussi 16,25 cinquième donc nos
traditions s'écrit aussi 16h25 cinquième
plus 16 5e et cette fois oui on peut
additionner des cinquièmes avec des 5e
et d'autres cas on obtient 32,25 5e
alors si vous faites ça à l'école vous
aurez raison
mais vous n'aurez peut-être pas juste
oui car les mathématiciens préfèrent
souvent des résultats entier quitte à
changer l'unité utilisée est ce qu'on ne
peut pas ajouter 13 car et 16 5e et
obtenir un résultat de la forme n est
mienne
l'astuce consiste à trouver une unité de
base dans laquelle treize carré 16 5e
sont tous deux des nombreux sentiers de
mm
et la plus petite valeur de m qui
parvient est appelé le plus petit
multiple commun de 4 et 5
et c'est souvent mais pas toujours la
multiplication entre les deux noms dans
notre caca 3,5 est égal à 20 et donc on
va tout convertir en 20e
il se trouve que 1/4 fait 5 20e tandis
qu'un cinquième fait quatre vingtième
mais alors 13/4 fonds 13 x 5 est égal à
65 20e alors que 16 5e font 16 x 4 est
égal à 60 4 20e
on voit alors qu'il y à un vingtième de
différence entre 13/4 et 16 5e et on
peut aussi remarquer que l'addition
entre 13,4 et 16 5 m est égal à 129 20e
la même astuce est devenu incontournable
pour gérer les nombreuses unités en
finance ou en physique pour comparer un
franc suisse et un dollar néo-zélandais
est en fait possible de tout convertir
en une monnaie de référence
disons par exemple en euro au taux de
change actuel
ceci nous fait 0 93 euro et 0,59 euro
clairement le franc suisse ou plus
certains économistes ont un temps
cherché à fixer tous les taux de change
pour que toutes les monnaies puissent
être amenés à une unité fondamentale
mais ils n'ont pas réussi
il se trouve que permettre au taux de
change de fluctuer fournit un levier
pour gouverner des politiques
financières
les physiciens eux ont eu plus de succès
sous l'impulsion notamment de napoléon
bonaparte
ils sont parvenus à standardiser les
unités de longueur en particulier le
maître a alors été définies de façon un
peu encombré ce qu il est vrai mais
contrairement à napoléon le mettre
ensuite conquis le monde
la mesure a pris la mesure de son être
le maître a même surpassé son être
et désormais tout le monde utilise le
maître tout le monde
non un petit village peuplé
d'irréductibles anglophone résiste
encore et toujours à la standardisation
des distances mais au moins en principe
aujourd'hui on pourrait mesurer vraiment
toutes les distances en mettre un pouce
fait après tout 00 254 m une unité
astronomique fait son milliard de m et 1
par seck fait 30 millions de milliards
de m toutes les unités de distance sont
en fait converti sable en être mais
qu'en est il des unités de temps de
température d'énergie de voltage
clairement ces unités ne peuvent pas
être mesurés en maître moins que
il se trouve que certaines unités
peuvent naturellement se décomposer en
d'autres par exemple une vitesse peut se
mesurer en une distance parcourue en un
temps donné
autrement dit on peut mesurer les
vitesses en kilomètres par heure nous
encore en mètre par seconde ce qui nous
ramène aux unités fondamental de
distance et de temps de la même manière
l'accélération d'une voiture peut se
mesurer par la vitesse que gagne la
voiture en un temps donné
si la voiture passe de 2 mètres par
seconde à 3 mètres par seconde en une
seconde
alors alors accéléré d'un mètre par
seconde par seconde
l'accélération peut donc se mesurer en
mètre par seconde par seconde ce qu'on
appelle aussi des mètres par seconde car
et parfois la conversion est un peu plus
complexe et s'appuie notamment sur des
lois de la physique par exemple la
seconde loi de newton nous dit que la
force exercée par un objet assure un
object et est égale à la masse de
l'objet b fois l'accélération qu'aurait
cet objet p6 seul l'objet a glissé sur
le bébé la force correspond donc à une
masse fois une accélération et donc à
des kilogrammes fois des maîtres / des
seconds carré en l'hommage à newton
cette unité un peu longue à écrire est
parfois appelé le newton mais de façon
intéressante elle est une composition d
unité fondamentale
mas de distance et de temps et ce n'est
pas la seule de même l'unité de pression
appelé le pascal mesure la quantité de
force exercée sur une surface donnée
elles se mesurent donc en newton par
mètre carré comme le newton et du
kilogramme fois des maîtres / des
secondes car et le pascal et donc du
seconds carré le tout divisé par des
mètres carrés se trouve que les maîtres
se simplifier un petit peu et on obtient
plus simplement des kilogrammes par
seconde carré par mètre
ce qui nous amène une anecdote
historique peut-être ce dock historique
quand einstein newton et pascal était
gamin et jouer à cache cache
l'orque einstein et et chats newton prix
tout à coup un morceau de craie et
dessine à un carré sur le sol d'un mètre
de côté et se mit à l'intérieur du car
et einstein se jeta sur newton écrit à
toucher oui répondit newton mais ce
n'est pas un newton que tu as trouvé
c'est un pascal que tu as trouvé car ce
que tu as trouvé est un newton par mètre
carré
vous avez compris un pascal et un newton
par mètre carré
sujette à la masse pas de pression je ne
vais pas utiliser la force pour que vous
riez
façon remarquable système international
a réussi à décomposer toutes les
grandeurs physiques y compris le voltage
de magnétisme l'énergie en une
multiplication et des visions de cette
unité fondamentale à savoir le maître du
défi mondial de la distance
la seconde l'unité fondamentale du temps
le kilogramme lite est fondamental de la
masse le kelvin l'unité fondamentale de
la température le candela l'unité
fondamentale de la luminosité lampert
l'unité fondamentale de l'intensité d'un
courant électrique et enfin la mole
unité fondamentale de la quantité de
matière ja c'est pas mal excellent de
même mais on peut faire mieux et même
beaucoup mieux pour unifier toujours
plus les unités de la physique
les physiciens ou eu l'idée de s'appuyer
sur les constantes fondamentales de la
physique ou plus précisément ils ont
fait la remarque que ces constantes
fondamentales peuvent servir de taux de
conversion naturel entre ses grandeurs
par exemple l'une des constantes
fondamentales de la physique et la
vitesse de la lumière
on note souvent c est qu il est égal à
300 millions de m par seconde et du coup
cette vitesse fondamentales de la
physique permet également de traduire
les mettre en seconde en un sens une
seconde c'est un peu l'équivalent de 300
millions de m et du coup une seconde
c'est à dire un milliardième de seconde
ça fait ça en distance et oui on
pourrait tout à fait à faire des
exercices de mesure à l'école avec une
crête traduit en nanosecondes lumière
lieu une autre façon d'imposer cette
conversion entre unités qui consiste à
considérer que les constantes
fondamentales de la physique sont des
grandeurs 100 unités égal à 1
ainsi si vous ouvrez un livre de
physique des particules
vous verrez rapidement que les
physiciens pose en effet c est égal à
d'autres constantes comme g ou h par est
égal à 1 6 6 en fait c et g et h par
sont des constantes fondamentales de
l'espace-temps de la gravité et de la
mécanique quantique
mais alors bizarrement 300 millions de m
deviennent littéralement égaux à une
seconde des constantes physiques nous
invite à considérer qu'il s'agit là du
taux de conversion naturelle entre la
seconde et le mettre dans notre univers
voilà qui permet en fait aux physiciens
de convertir toutes les unités du
système international et donc toutes les
grandeurs physiques vers une seule et
unique unité fondamentale
cette unité fondamentale aurait très
bien pu être le maître et ça aurait très
bien pu être la seconde mais il se
trouve que pour des raisons historiques
les physiciens ont préféré choisir les
électrons volts qui était en fête
originalement une unité d'énergie mais
qui sert désormais à mesurer tout en
physique en particulier désormais les
électrons volt ne mesure pas que de
l'énergie via les constantes de la
physique
c'est devenu aussi une unité de temps de
distance de masse de température et de
toutes les grandeurs physiques
imaginable en physique des particules
tout comme en physique quantique des
champs ou en théorie des cordes les
physiciens utilise qu'une seule unité
selon cette théorie tout ne serait
qu'une affaire d'énergie mois que en
1973 un physicien appelé jacob bécane
stein remarqua que si les trous noirs
n'avaient pas d'autres au pis alors il
serait possible de violer la seconde loi
de la thermodynamique
les détails de ce que ça signifie sans
complexe peut les oublier pour
aujourd'hui
toujours est il que ce constat est
absolument catastrophique car la seconde
loi de la thermodynamique est souvent
considérée comme étant la loi la plus
fiable de toute la physique
einstein disait telle qu'elle était la
seule théorie physique universel dont il
était convaincu qu'elle ne serait jamais
rejeté
pour sauver la seconde douanes à terme
et dynamique les trous noirs devaient
avoir une entropie et pas n'importe
laquelle
à l'aide de calcul heuristique à
l'interface entre la thermodynamique la
relativité générale et la mécanique
quantique des canes stein postulat que
l'entropie d'un trou noir était
proportionnel à la surface qui entoure
ce trou noir
mieux encore pour sauver la seconde loi
de la thermodynamique
il fut obligé de postuler que cette
entropie était maximale autrement dit
dans un volume d espace donné il est
impossible de stocker plus d'information
qu'une certaine constante fondamentale
fois la surface qui entoure cet espace
cette équation alors un peu spéculative
est aujourd'hui connu sous le nom de
limites de bekenstein l'année suivante
stephen hawking montre à l'existence des
rayonnements des trous noirs ce qui lui
permit de développer une thermodynamique
des trous noirs qui justifiait les
calculs de bekenstein plus étonnant
encore en 1995 des jacobsson prouva que
cette simple inégalités impliquer la
relativité générale d'einstein
mais surtout en 2008 aux radios cassini
démontre à la limite de bernstein dans
le cadre de la théorie quantique des
champs depuis la limite de bekenstein
inspiré le principe holographique qui
dit plus généralement que tout notre
univers peut être vue comme la
projection d'un hologramme purement
informationnelle et dont l'information
est stockée sur la surface qui entoure
notre univers enfin de façon remarquable
comme l'expliquent gilles dowek cette
limite de bekenstein est ce qui justifie
la thèse fondamentale de church turing
via le théorème de gandhi bref la limite
bekenstein sa part est en fait être
quelque chose de vraiment fondamental en
tout cas de façon cruciale pour nous
cette limite est de bernstein montre
surtout qui semble y avoir un taux de
conversion naturelle entre la surface
qui entoure un espace physique mesure 1
mètre carré ou en 1 / des électrons
volts au carré et l'information à
l'intérieur de la surface qu'un
informaticien mesurerait en bits ou dit
autrement même l'unité fondamentales de
la physique théorique n'est qu'une
mesure indirecte d'une quantité
d'informations bref vous l'avez vu venir
il semble que l'univers n'est qu'une
affaire cbe
8 francs
disait le physicien john wheeler et si
vous vous écoutez des physiciens de
premier rang comme jeune carole brian
greene ou leonardo skins vous verrez que
ce discours est en fait devenu commun au
sein de la physique théorique la plus
fondamentale qui soit
en fait toutes les notions de distance
de temps et d'énergie mais aussi de
température de charge et de magnétisme
tous ne seraient que des mesures
indirectes d'une forme de quantité
d'informations l'univers ne serait donc
intérêt d'information thibault david et
moi nous sommes tous des pictes à moins
que vous voyez un truc qui n'ont que
d'entre eux raisonnement notre univers
et cantiques même si on a tendance à se
concentrer sur des aspects descriptible
de manière classique et si notre univers
et quantique c'est que l'information de
notre univers est en fait une histoire
non pas de beats classique mais deux
bits quantiques aussi appelé cuite et
donc en fait probablement non l'univers
n'est pas une histoire des pictes
l'univers est en fait une histoire de
cul et de 8,9
les de penser en termes de paris et vous
avez évité a dû réfléchir notamment à la
prise de décisions et en fait que vous
prenez un pari à chaque prise de
décision et que ça serait plus judicieux
d'analyser la prise de décision que les
résultats de la prise de décision qui
souvent plein d'incertitudes et
d'inconnu et de choses qu'on ne contrôle
pas et malheureusement j'avais fait la
remarque que dans la loi souvent en
justice on fait plus attention aux
résultats qu'à la prise de décision et
emmanuel franquemagne fait la remarque
oui en effet c'est le cas dans la
plupart des textes de loi mais il ya des
agressions qui sont absolument
remarquable de tout cela notamment un
texte le texte 122,7 qui protègent les
personnes qui viennent en assistance à
des personnes en danger même si l'or
aide est en fait contre pau de grives et
conduit à des conséquences qui sont
dramatiques
c'est très intéressant puisque cet ex du
coup juge la prise de décision de la
personne qui voulait aider et va être
clémente si la personne voulait vraiment
aidé mais a raté son assistance à autrui
avec des conséquences potentiellement
tragique
al'inverse il ya le texte 223,6 qui
punit l'absence d'assistance à autrui je
fais ça va être intéressant
cette réflexion qu'il ya dans ces textes
de loi sur la prise de décision et non
pas sur le résultat de la prise de
décision
j'espère qu'ils avaient aimé cette vidéo
donc on a fait un petit détour sur la
théorie de l'information on va parler
encore un peu plus d'informations dans
les prochaines vidéos et vous verrez
qu'en fait c'est ultra utiles pour mieux
comprendre des notions comme le hasard
par exemple mieux réfléchir qu'est ce
que le raja et surtout ce à la lumière
du pétainisme ça va permettre d'éclairer
beaucoup de choses qui à mon goût sont
souvent pas très bien débattu notamment
par manque de recul épistémologie vous
avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à la
laquerre commentaires et partager pensez
à vous abonner pour les futurs épisodes
merci au type erp radon et j'espère que
vous serez là la prochaine fois
et si oui ce matin qu'aucun intérêt de
la mauvaise spirale